you've probably heard of a pride of
lions a pot of whales a swarm of bees
maybe even a murder of crows but how
about a parliament of owls a shrewdness
of Apes an obstinacy of Buffalo a bask
of crocodiles or a convocation of eagles
wait why is this happening why should
every speeches get their own collective
noun no one could ever memorize all
these the practice called terms of
venery dates back to the aristocratic
hunting traditions of the late Middle
Ages it was an Insider jargon to tell
who the real Hunters were did you hear
rodri of herfordshire say pack of foxes
everyone knows it's called a skull kind
of like how modern sports fans have
their own slang like actually I don't
know any sports slang over the years it
developed into a playful linguistic
custom a way to sound clever at Social
Gatherings which is basically what it
still is today it has no other real
purpose so the next time you're at to
party and someone says actually it's a
drift of pigs feel free to drift away